Hello, it's me, Markiplier.
Here with another video of questionable quality.
And, by questionable quality, I mean
I don't know how this one's gonna go
I just kinda thought this up on a whim and
I don't know if the results are going to meet expectations,
But then again, expectations are usually low.
So, to describe this idea,
and give you even more trepidation
on the fact that you clicked on this video,
I'm going to be going through
various quotev.com quizzes.
Which, if you know about quotev,
you know they are of THE GREATEST QUALITY
and you can't be beat with their discount quizzes.
So I'm going to go through them and, HOPEFULLY,
find my true love,
both on the boyfriend side and the girlfriend side.
Because, at this point, I'm so desperate I'll take anything
Uh a ah...
Whatever, you know I'm not even gonna preface it
anymore because, the more I talk,
the more people leave so...
"You are Youtuber Boyfriend".
I am?  Me am?  I am Youtuber Boyfriend?
Is that me? Ohh, thank you for noticing.
Ohhhh, it's made with MEMES.
I can't read these memes.
I need to get my meme goggles on here.
Hang on, let me put in my monocle.
Hang on, one second here.
Uh huh, Uh huh.
MY GOD.. That is an ancient meme.
The fuck is that?
OH! I still can't read it.
HUH.
Let me look into this one.
NOPE.
Ye- oh wait yo-o-oh oh yeah oh, I found it.
*spastic editing*
Yeah, okay, it's a waste of my time.
"Are you ready?" ...uhh, sure I guess.
Alright let's go red-green, cause green.
Ehh, singing and dancing.
I-I like me some singing and dancing, that's pretty good.
Fate... Big fate? Oh boy.
Alright how 'bout the bottom one.
"Perfect, rich, popular, hot, cute,
someone every guy wants."
I mean, if you had any option that was gonna be me,
it's obviously gonna be that one. Right guys?!
WHO THE FUCK IS THAT?! WHO ARE YOU?!
*Angry mumbling* Answered 3 out of 6 answers correctly?!
What does that mean? What do you mean "correctly"?!
And I'm shocked that I got 'em correct cause there were so many answers!
*sound from video begins playing*
Ahhh that's right he was part of this thing.
This.. this thing that retired at the ripe age of not old.
Okay .
*mark mumbles some more*
Alright that.. that.. I hate that.
That guy, *chuckles*
is Mr. PewDiePie.
I know that guy, I copy him everyday.
Who are those guys?
Uhhh I-I just did hot yoga recently with Ian
It was lovely.
Who's that guy?
I don't know!
Why do you have specific names on that guy?
Who's that guy?!
Alright, fine. Ricky.
That guy looks like a Ricky.
"How many Youtubers can you name?"
No idea, Tyler Oakley, somebody, somebody, somebody,
Uhhhh, I think that's Grace Helbig.
Somebody, somebody,
Is that Fred? I think that's Fred.
Zoom in on that... me
'cause I'm editing this one
Dats Fred. Dats Poodipoo.
smowsh.
Don't know.
Zoella?
Don't know, don't know.
Is that Merzia?
No idea, no idea, no idea, no idea.
Pffft, fuck those guys.
Nope, nope, nope.
That's mister Dawson... I think.
How many was that?
I don't know. Maybe twenty. Somethin' like that
Who's that cutie over here? I have no idea.
It's a stock photo! I don't know!
A Youtuber?!
Who's that? Ahh! It's Ian
That's Ian. He's got the bowl cut I remember.
That's definitely Ian.
That's "John", "Felix", "some random Youtuber".
Ahhh... "some random Youtuber".
Mr. Graceffa. Do you like Youtube?
God, no.
*stammering*
What does that have to do with anything
that we were doing before?
You just pulled up Justine!
That had nothing to do with a
goddamn thing that I just did!
Alright, okay.
Okay.
Alri- Here's ano-
I'm doin' another one. Cause why not?
Okay, alright.
Green.
Favorite animal. Dog.
Favorite school- Now this is more like it.
A personality based quiz.
Take the elements of my life that are extremely boring
and everybody probably knows
and then determine my future from it!
"Favorite class", "school activity".
*moans*
Music, I guess.
"How do you spend your free time?"
Eugheh, video games isn't an option.
Why is video games not an option?
Looking at me social media to see how awesome I am.
That's me.
"What kind of TV shows do you watch?"
Can I put "Who's Line is it Anyway?"
Because literally the only TV show I ever watch is that
and "Stranger Things".
An-and anime apparently because there's no other choices here.
"What kind of video games do you play?"
There we go.
I don't play horror on my own.
I like me a nice good old adventure game.
Uh, I live in... It's not the suburbs.
A city!
Let's see..
"What gender are you?"
MAAAAN!
"Favorite food?"
Chicken and dumplins!
Mmmm!
There's no option for chicken and dumplins here.
It's kind of a mixture between all these.
Except PURE lard.
If you could just put me lard in a bucket,
and then make it into dumpling shapes,
and then maybe put a chicken in it.
I won't ask what type of meat it is.
That's my favorite food.
That one right there.
Meat... I guess.
"Do you like peepo?"
Do-do I like "THE Peepo"?
I need to Google what "The Peepo" is!
Mona: Ahh...
Ruster...
can...
bring a.....
friend...
to dinner?
Ruster: *whimpers strangely*
Mona: No!
Ruster: *makes strange laughing sound*
'Mona: Cause Ruster
*incomprehensible*
Mona: Samado
Snudder Mado
And a Cushie... and a
*incomprehensible*
Shoosh
And a Shoosher
*incomprehensible*
And hooooo nasa
Peepo
Mark: *laughing*
*laughing*
*more lauging*
What is that?
Mona: -ooo nasa
Peepoo
Mark: What's a peepo- *trails off into laughter*
Is this in a different language or is that actually English?
I went into that thinking it was horrifying,
and then as soon as it got to Shoosh
*laughing*
Shooooooosh
SHOOOOOSH
*laughing hysterically*
then that's a peepo
*laughs*
*chuckles*
I like a da Peepo.
I can firmly say now that I like a da Peepo.
I don't know who that is!
But, ya' know what? Le-let's find out!
This is apparently deterministic by this quiz.
This is my YouTube girlfriend so...
Let's see what ya got.
*chuckling*
What is this?
Drake and Josh?
I, hang on a second.
Oh, Jesus.
*laughing*
Oh, God. Oh, God.
Now this is something that I can get into.
I am a hundred percent down with this kind of content.
*laughing*
If this is exactly what we are gonna
get out of this channel,
then, I think- I think this is an accurate choice!
Am I having a fever dream right now?
I can't exactly remember what I was supposed
to be doing.
Ah, ooh, yes. Oh, yes.
Oh, yes more. Please more!
What'd ya got?
Ooh, ooh. I love it.
Okay, what's popular?
What'd ya got?
Ooh.
*Creepy background music plays*
Undertale.
Undertale, Undertale, Undertale,
Undertale, Undertale, Undertale, Undertale,
Undertale, Undertale,
Undertale, Undertale, Undertale
I-I don't know how to tell you this Jenny,
I don't think this one's gonna work.
Uh, I-just we don't see eye to eye.
*sluring*
I just need to escape please.
Goodbye. Sorry. Sorry, Jenny
Sorry. Sorry, it's just.
It was- it was nice while it lasted.
Uugh, okay. Alright, I'm gonna do a couple more.
I'm going to do one more girlfriend quiz,
and one more boyfriend quiz.
Because I don't think the boyfriend ones
have been very good thus far.
So I need to find a good.
You heard that right.
I need to find a GOOOOOD boyfriend
"What do you see in a girl?"
Uhhhh...
bluuUUUGH
Intestines, organs...
Uhhh, literally a lot of shit.
Like...
I mean, I don't wanna be tha-
I'm not saying girls are full of shit.
I'm saying,
literally we as a human species
ar-are just giant bags of shit.
Walking around on two legs and just
finding places to drop our inane bullshit
wherever we may go.
We're gonna build a wall.
I don't caare about th-
"Funny".
...uuuh
"Eye Color".
I don't care about...
*making noises*
"Brown".
...Color is m-
Wait, is... uh, my hair?
"Red".
Yeah!
"You hate it when a girl..."
Never lets me talk,
because if there's one thing I need to do
It's talk a LOT.
Let's see, favorite fud?
*growls*
Nnnn, everything.
No, not something healthy!
Oh, God!
Oh, what have I done?!
Oh, no!!
Oh, God!! Ohh, nooo!!
Aahhhh!!
I fucked it!
I'll never find love now!
Alright, "What can't you live without?"
My Compooter.
"Favorite color".
*groans*
"Friends describe you"...
Ha- No, hot, strong, and popular.
If I had friends
they'd say those exact things!
And my three friends right here
Larry, Moe and Curly
Larry, Moe and...
Bubblebee!
Larry, Moe, and
Bigglesworth!
Larry, Moe and, and, and, and, and, and, and
Billfred!
Would say that I'm hot, strong, and popular.
"What app do you use the most?"
Yoouutuuube
*stammering*
I-If ye... I-if-if YE got married
Where would ye want to live?
Uh, Cincinnati, Ohio in America
Which is yer Fav?
Drake and Josh!
DRAKE AND JOSH!!
Yes!
Yes! Yeeaaahh!
*laughing*
Drake and Josh
"What would you get her for her birthday?"
Ahhhhh...
I'm gonna go the...
I'm gonna go the price is right route.
and go for the highest monetary value
because in my opinion
that's what determines everything
Hurray!
TheGabbieShow!
Who is that?
I don't know these people.
I should know this
I should know this!
Who are you?!
*video making jumpcuts*
Gabbie: I, I, I,
*audio slowed down*
Gabbie: I
Gabbie: I don't know
that I can read it.
I'm going to do my very best.
But it's gonna make me, like I ca-
*laughing*
*Gabbie Show Intro music*
Mark: What is it?!
What is it?!!
What?!
Gabbie: Welcome back!
Mark: Oh, hi.
Gabbie: Do you know when something's SO embarrassing
that nobody else is even around
and you are embarrassed with YOURSELF?
Mark: No I don't know that.
Gabbie: Because you
Gabbie: know that YOU know
Mark: No.
Gabbie: That that person existed
Mark: I-I don't know.
Gabbie: You know
Mark: No.
*high pitch*
Mark: Don't know that
Gabbie: YOU Know
*higher pitch*
Mark: I-I don't know!
*gasps*
Wait! Hang on!
ZOOM IN ON THAT HAIR!
*dramatic horn plays*
Oh my God.
*whsipering*
Ssshh what the fucking fuck?
*still whispering*
What the fuck?
Fuck!
What the shit?!
WHAT THE FUCK!?
It's fake!
OH FUCK!
You fucking with me?!
Look at this!
L-LOOK AT THIS!
I'm trying to-
IT...
WHAAaaaoo
*Gabbie talking in the background*
It's destiny.
Mark: Ugh
I'm READY! Bring it on!
Gabbie: Oh, hold on!
Mark: I'm waiting. I- I'm not go-
I can pause the video...
*Gabbie talking in the background*
Ooooh...
*Gabbie continues talking in the background*
Mark: Nice...
Wait, should I- should I put on make up too?
*Heavy Metal music begins playing*
Mark: I'm ready.
Bring on the EMO.
I've been transformed.
All right, lay it on to me.
*giggling*
Gabbie: This is so uncomfortable!
Mark: Me too!
Mark: The neck thing.
Gabbie: Okay, first poem slash song
"Tears of Acid"
"Down my cheek roll acid tears"
"They've been burning all these years"
"Scarring streaks forever stain"
"Someone help me ease this pain!'
"Look down deep, there's nothing there"
*music cut by stifled laughter*
*holding back laughter*
"I'm hiding all my trembling fears"
"look deeper still into my heart"
"it's been torn and ripped apart."
"Beneath the surface, something lurks"
"I found out nothing ever works."
Mark: Okay, that was pretty good.
That was pretty good
I think it's a good match
But I gotta do a final test here.
We really gotta know if this one.
is gonna last.
*Suspensful crescendo*
Mark: YEAH!!!
*Victory orchestra begins playing*
OHHH BE FREE MY HEEEEAAART!
*Screeches in victory*
So, unfortunately I am out of time
Which is sad because I thought I'd
be able to do another Youtuber boyfriend quiz
but I guess fate just does not want me to find my
SOUL MATE
of the boyish variety
BUT!
I did find TRUE LOVE dee-
ow, fuck, I got to stop doing that, ow!
Deep, deep down in MY heart,
my stone cold emo heart,
in the form
of a quiz on this stupid website.
so, if you wanna see me do MORE
quizzes or tests and or things on this stupid site,
then let me know down in the comments below.
I like stupid ideas because
sometimes they're the most fun to do.
So I hope you enjoyed this!
Let me know down in the comments below
and thank you to everybody that I...
...made fun of over here
I'll put their links as well in the description.
I won't forget about you
Or Jenny
Or what's-his-face.
So thanks again, and as always...
I will see YOU
in the next video.
BUH-Bye!
GUUHHH